hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play death unknown
okay if the guy who recommended this to
me was right this one should be an
absolutely terrifying adventure so turn
down the lights put on your headphones
sit back and get ready to crap your
pants too something along those lines
okay controls pretty simple WASD to move
eat interact f4 flashlight this is made
on the Unity engine so it should prove
to have some decent type of graphics
where am I
last thing I remember is that the boat
crashed I need to keep calm and find
some help yeah do that
see flashlights oh hello okay the boat
has crashed
there's the water's edge and there's
some plank of wood over there so we
could seem I'm guessing they were on
some sort of island keep out you know
what screw your warning she's all around
us who's she is she beautiful can she be
seduced by my manly charms I heard that
what's there in the woods I seem to be
it's not a phone why is there a phone
out here what the oh what wait what this
doesn't make much sense Oh whoop where'd
this come from why is there a house on a
middle of an island okay whatever I'm
not gonna
hi okay thank you for closing the door
manners everybody okay all right then
that's good glad for you can I hide in
here yep it's just like my days back and
amnesia designed in a closet oh my
goodness I think my battery is running
low
my flashlight there's a little meter
case you were wondering my mama why my
face is on the other hello are you a
mask or are you an actual mannequin head
I don't think I want to know the answer
to that okay every door seems to be
locked which is a good sign I guess Oh
what is that sound you keep doing that I
don't I don't particularly know okay so
the pain of that de painting okay good I
thought there was something fuzzy
batteries that is a creepy painting Wow
okey all right okay
hi lady
did you just poke your head through that
moon okay alright then I'll go excuse me
sorry didn't mean to interrupt your
beauty time what the hell I gotta give
this game kudos for the ambience it's
definitely uh heart pounding look the
hell's in light that was knocked over
there's some more batteries over there
I'll save them until I get low again
hello okay all right okay all right okay
okay okay okay okay
all right just going into this dark
basement all by myself all by my
lonesome no one to protect me what is
that what is that what is that what is
that what is that what is it pick up a
kid I didn't even see the key what is
that oh you that's a hand with a finger
missing why this
I'm so confused sir these body bags are
they long clumps of hair oh I don't want
to know I don't want to know I don't
want to know I don't want to know I just
want to go home
who's that more batteries okay
okay good I guess maybe good locked that
might be the way out
I've no idea huh this place gives me the
heebie-jeebies I got it I'm just kind of
freaked out right now
okay I'm sorry
also I got the like what do you play
these horror games just try playing it
with okay the volume turned way up it
makes it so much worse
ah screw you lady lady lady lady lady
screw you I was that key only to that or
did I get another key I don't know what
happened
what battery's where I don't even see
where you're pointing
okay not that okay not that either I
don't even know if I still have a key I
don't know what I got oh good
Oh is there anyone on the phone can i
phone for help please call the police
dear God please somebody call the police
somebody call the police call them to
this strange Island that I'm on and make
them show up with lots of big guns I
don't think they're gonna help but it'd
make me feel better okay I don't know I
might be lost for a bit here which
should be just fine with me because that
means nothing's gonna happen where
something is gonna happen I don't know I
think I'd go back down to the base but
because I got another key but I don't
know what it's too then go outside I
cannot oh joyous Jay Oh frabjous day
Callooh Callay I get to go down into the
basement again I don't recall there
being another lock thumb rather I got
even know what was in here didn't look
like anything was in there oh well
whatever whatever here we go
goody goody gumdrops okay okay okay okay
okay so I got the key from in here right
so that means there's got to be
something else
oh stop it I know it's probably not
gonna do anything oh the key was to that
why to here where am I where the hell am
I am I going off the island a little
like that got dark circle so yeah that
was the ending that got me good
oh I got it oh I got a tweak in my
shoulder from that last one okay that
was pretty good short but sweet that's
the way I like it cuz then I get to walk
away from the nightmare later on hahaha
oh man that was really good I mean this
is an example of why sound plays such a
huge factor in these things because I'm
especially got the volume cranked up in
your surround sound headphones because
I'm in a horror game I was set up right
from the beginning that we just the
ambience was good that's why you need to
have that there
and oh man I seriously got tweaking my
neck from that last what no is a good
one so anyway that's all for now thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos than I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
huh
look over there what over there
my doors turn blue didn't something say
that when my torch turned blue I need to
run ah